l'intérieur du palais
le Sénat comme vous ne l'avez jamais
entendu
levez les yeux la coupole est immense
son diamètre avoisine 7 mètres de
largeur et sa circonférence est de 21
mètres
2834 à 1841 sous la monarchie juillet
ont construit la miss cycle ou siège
désormais le Sénat ainsi que la salle de
lecture principale de la bibliothèque en
1840 c'est le peintre Eugène Delacroix
qui est choisi pour décorer la coupole
ainsi que le demi-cercle qui surplombe
l'immense fenêtre de la bibliothèque
en 1841 quand de la croix et son élève
Gustave de la salle Bordes commence les
travaux
s'imagine-t-il qu'il dureront six ans
Eugène Delacroix aime la littérature
pour les deux œuvres de la bibliothèque
il choisit de s'inspirer d'une scène
tirée de la Divine Comédie de Dante
dans la coupole de la Croix installe
quatre groupes de personnages quand vous
entrez dans la bibliothèque vous vous
trouvez néanez avec Orphée le fondateur
mythique de la poésie entouré de la
poétesse Sapho à sa gauche et du poète
eziote à sa droite si vous vous
retournez vous pourrez découvrir un
autre groupe de poètes au-dessus de la
porte d'entrée de la bibliothèque
Homère s'appuie sur un bâton semblable
un sceptre face à lui Dante revêtue d'un
habit rouge s'incline dans un mouvement
de vénération
au pied d’omer un ange appuisé dans la
fontaine de l'inspiration afin de donner
de son nom à dents
la scène traduit la succession des
poètes à travers les âges
de part et d'autre de la coupole de la
Croix place des personnages grecs et
romains
[Musique]
le groupe des Grecs s'organise autour de
Socrate et d'Alexandre le Grand habillé
en guerrier le roi des Macédoniens
s'appuie sur l'épaule de son précepteur
le philosophe Aristote
de l'autre côté se trouve le groupe des
Romains où la place principale est
donnée à Katon duthique les bras levés
ils s'apprête à se donner la mort par
l'épée au lendemain de la défaite des
troupes prestés fidèles à la République
romaine face à celle de César
c'est justement ce dernier que vous
voyez dans le fond de la Seine avec un
groupe de Romains il fait face à
Alexandre le Grand de l'autre côté de la
coupole
en considérant la taille des deux
personnages vous devinerez aisément
lequel des deux à la préférence de
Delacroix Alexandre le Grand bien sûr
le peinte lui a même consacré le cul de
four de la bibliothèque
il y est représenté vainqueur après la
bataille d'Arvel assis sur le trône de
son ennemi Darius roi des Perses dont il
reçoit les femmes et les enfants
un épisode important qui permet à
Alexandre le Grand de devenir roi d'Asie
[Musique]
d'un ample mouvement du bras droit
Alexandre demande au macédonien de
déposer le rouleau de l'Iliade dans un
coffre dérobé au Perse par ce geste il
montre que le poème d'Homère et la chose
la plus précieuse qui lui est appartenu
[Musique]
le message est clair la poésie née avec
Homère doit être protégée et transmise
aux générations futures
préserver et transmettre l'art la
littérature la culture la civilisation
ce grand cycle de Delacroix est toujours
d'actualité
[Musique]